foreign
Channel 8 we've been covering a lot
about the homeless problems plaguing the
valley but where can some of those
people go for help Madison Kimbrough
spoke to a local Treatment Facility Who
sheds light on the ongoing issue she
joins us near Main Street in Washington
with the story
located right in the heart of the
homeless Corridor near downtown Vegas
stronger's goal is to take someone who's
living on the streets and move them into
a more permanent stable situation a lot
of the shelters while they do do great
work aren't offering the serious mental
illness treatment drug and alcohol
treatment that we think people need so
they can get back on their feet and
stable over the long term Ryan Hamilton
the community relations organizer for
Vegas stronger shares what their focus
is as a treatment center he acknowledges
how bad the homeless problem has become
with mental illness being at the
Forefront and what once was a problem in
certain pockets of Vegas has now become
a valley-wide issue homelessness is a
big concern for many residential
neighborhoods we've followed the story
that you did on homelessness the impact
of the growth of the homeless population
is really reaching out into all parts of
the city right now at Vegas stronger
people can come and see a clinician with
three doctors on site including two
psychiatrists and a medical prescriber I
got tired of the up and down get sent
here get sent there and
I was given the opportunity to go to
treatment Brandon light a recovering
addict and now three years clean as a
case manager at the treatment facility I
was born and raised in Las Vegas right I
know early on that the city can eat
people up and it led me to six years of
homelessness multiple juvenile
facilities uh prison twice all starting
at the age of 16. and there are 2500
shelter beds located within a half a
mile walk of Vegas stronger and when I
asked what the main type of mental
illness they see on a regular basis walk
through their doors schizophrenia was at
the top of their list reporting near
Main Street and Washington Madison
Kimbrough 8 News Now